you want to take
the coochie started having puppies last
night about 7:00 do you know when the
last puppy she had was
4:00 it's been 4 hours since Coogi last
birthed the puppy her labor has
stalled I know I had come here he is
he's
okay she has been agitated she's not
really pay attention to her birth or
continuing to have the rest of the
puppies here coochi we're just concerned
that if there was puppy stuck we don't
want to have her be in a
mess hey only one what the heck's going
on it's a big lab and normally these big
dogs don't have trouble having puppies
but she does she ain't done nothing for
a while well let me feel if there's any
more and if not I'll take an x-ray and
go from there hang on to
it
okayi that is nothing there that I can
feel and that looks
clean when I reach in vagin that is
nothing there so there's not a pup
that's stuck you and I are going
downstairs for an x-ray I think that's
more important now to know what's there
yes thank
you
just little keep it there for
now oh yeah there's a whole bunch of
pups yet and nothing is
stuck we take a downstairs pickax rays
and yes there's still pups left four or
five
more so let's try with oxytocin see if
she can deliver
them the hormone oxytocin causes the
uterus to contract jump starting labor
again okay I don't want to do it here
cuz I don't want puppy coming out on the
way home they only live a few miles away
they have cattle so they know how to
give shots so she can give Gucci the
oxidos at home and see if she can get a
labor started one cc at a time 6 cc give
her a shot see if there's a pop coming
then she stalls again give her another
shot soon give her one and wait how long
usually within an hour there's one okay
and then with 2 hours no nothing more
give her another shot ideally with the
help of oxytocin coochi can give birth
in the comfort of home if it doesn't
work let us
know if nothing comes then she can come
back and we'll help her out there is
room it's just that the uterus is not
Contracting uh we're feeling relieved
we're happy that everything's still
going well it's just taking a very long
time here in the part working
lot Tucker now he is a teenager he's
kind of a handful and 25 miles
away patch is a 12-year-old Appaloosa
he's got a really goofy
personality two
horses are potentially suffering from
degenerative
diseases moon
blindness we had actually had to put one
of our other horses down because he got
it and string Hal if he has string Holt
then he'll go lame within 2
years
hello
hello string halt is a muscular skeletal
disorder where there is abnormal tendon
tightness would you walk him just kind
of in a straight line for me it's
something that we diagnose by watching
the horse move around the horse will
start abnormally lifting their leg when
they walk it's called
hyperflexion multiple causes can trigger
string hold and there isn't always a fix
and if you could try and get him to trot
up and down
too like string hold moon blindness can
also result from various factors and
maybe incurable hold still hey I it's me
Tucker's eye is not looking good at all
but that's not moon blindness I don't
see anything that looks like string halt
to me neither case is what the owners
suspected that that's an injury right in
the corner there and that hurts like the
Dickens I know I feel bad for it
yeah this is an infection in the eye I
am so thankful it's not moon blindness
there's a poke in there on this side it
could be a stick or just a branch or
even like a rose hook you think he
didn't come back for a sight if you
don't try it you don't know I know I
know that's what I figured
eyes take a long time but if you don't
do it you'll never
win we'll put drops and sa in the eye
from the outside and then from the
inside we use antibiotic 5 CC per 100 lb
every 48 hours I would say three or four
shots in a row and then I'll get your
drops and I'll get you Sav so it takes a
long time for an eye to heal but I've
seen them heal up so I don't give up too
easy
here's your bag of goodies if you run
out and it's still a so so just come
back for more we don't have to see the
horse again okay okay thank you thank
you thank you good seeing
you I think it's more likely to be
Shivers than string H
halt horses with Shivers have damage in
the area of the brain that controls
muscle
movement he seems fine
otherwise Shivers is not a painful
disease it just probably feels a little
odd but it's definitely not painful
sometimes feeding a diet that's higher
in fat and lower in starch can reduce
the symptoms um I don't think it's going
to affect his performance probably for
quite some time he has plenty of good
riding years ahead of him it's just
something he's going to be dealing with
all right thank you enjoy the sunshine I
feel more relieved that it's not string
H halt it's not as severe as it can be
mobile fora base
time finished anything
new and this is Zeus
yeah Zeus has had some bad luck of
late little guy
yeah Zeus come on come on spe his leg
was amputated just a few days ago and
now he's got another
problem hello how are you I'm not back
so what's going on with this one he's
had a rough week he has a very rough
week well he has learned how to balance
himself and his leg oh interesting
so I think that he probably tipped and
he probably caught a stick owie
owie yeah this probably
hurts Zeus recently had a amputation of
his limb so he's working on trying to
figure out how to balance on three legs
and had a accident while going to the
bathroom yesterday and actually fell
over and injured his eye it's got a
giant divot in its eye it's so big I can
see it yeah I knew something was on
yesterday he was just laying in the
crate and I'm like what is wrong with he
doesn't feel good it was all good see y
he hasn't ruptured through the cornea
yet which is
fantastic yeah we don't want that to
happen and we're going to just put him
on some medications to help him heal
that so drops for the eye that you're
going to do hopefully four times a day
our best you can do okay I'll go get
meds I'll be right back sounds good
thank you
yep dogs figure it out like I've got
three legs okay we're going to get it
done this way but falling over within
the first few weeks sometimes
happens okay I decided because it's so
large we're going to put him on drops
and ointment okay we're going to do it
drop in his eye and then we just wait
about a minute and then we'll put
ointment across it okay the cornea needs
to heal so we're going to use some
antibiotics for him and this will take
about a week or so and he should be good
as new
yeah ouch ouch I'm excited that you
actually have your eye open cuz if my
eye look like that it would be closed I
think it's got a lot to do with the pain
meds that he on for the L yeah oh I know
we've messed with it too much this this
morning haven't we one more time and
we'll leave you alone for right now
carefully work his eyelids a little bit
with that ointment just so it kind of
melts okay okay Tada good boy so today's
Zeus's lucky day his eye should heal up
well and everything's good he'll be
three-legged still but he'll have both
his eyes super happy about
that know you eat your own cat food you
haven't finished it yet Tommy is a
little stray kitten that came into the
clinic
nope Tommy was abandoned he tested
negative for all the diseases so we
erased him up made him healthy and
you're purring oh my he's purring look
crazy Tommy's very friendly he's a cute
little kitten Dr Paul kind of fell in
love with it let go oh ow
sorry I know that if we do have to give
Tommy away Dr pul will be sad but I know
he really doesn't want to part with
him what get rid of those needles here
Tomy is such an easygoing cat and that's
the thing even feal cats and especially
young ones can easily be
tamed you get to be a good cat you be in
barn playing with the
roosters coochi is back come on it's
been 5 hours oh yeah back and the
hormone shots haven't worked as
[Music]
hoped we got one more we got
two coochi had only one more
puppy so I don't remember what it was 9
or 10 when we got home this morning that
was L nothing since nothing pushing not
really maybe a few times but no okay
cooie's labor stalled again with several
puppies still
inside you're okay you're okay they're
okay you're okay
yes nothing enough just one hey how much
o has she had whatever you gave us all
of it
yeah let me get a glove and see if
there's any stuck she's not laboring
really at all or nothing no she's big
enough that they should come
out now see and there's nothing that I
can feel
again
H she she's panting so bad which many
times is a sign of e clamps here and E
clamps is like milk fever e clamps here
in dog is a lack of
calcium sometimes it's a lack of
calcium come here the other one it was
alive huh
mhm an oral dose of calcium should boost
contractions oh it doesn't taste bad
come
on okay give you five minutes and I'm
coming back giving a shot of
oxytocin all right 5 minutes is just
enough time for a quick hello to common
that's good and a strategic refuel that
coffee is cold and now made
new one last dose of
oxytocin push right okay I'll wait and
see then I can fly it out I
wish well everyone waits for Coogi to
start pushing
again with this Trio coming in it's
about to get loud in
here there buta lives a long ways away
so when she comes she makes it
worthwhile so she bring in all her
animals that don't look good my goodness
here you are again hello now she has a
cat a goat and a bunny did you have room
for yourself in the car no it stunk so
bad okay this is who this is Jorge and
what is she doing he just was squatting
the other day after we changed the
litter and he's just sitting there for 5
minutes squatting I didn't know if
anything was wrong I was on my way and I
just thought it had no his BL is
complete normal I didn't know if he was
trying to poop or pee or what but he's
just squatting and squatting probably
try to poop okay hang on for a sec he's
got tape
herbs when animals have tape worms the
segments of the tape worm actually crawl
out the back end it looks gross see that
thing there okay let's warm them and
call it quit Okay that's what does
hold still no just a
second there okay he goes back in well
can he stay out he's like really mouthy
when he's in there okay and this is the
rabbit yeah he's been super dirty and I
picked him up and looked at his
underneath and he's just so sick I
didn't know no you yes but I mean he's
got no weight on him no but I feel bad
cuz it's been a couple weeks and his pen
is full of pee he probably has a year
trct infection so that's what we're
going to do first heg the bunny is all
dirty actually urinating all over and
that most likely is urinary tract
infection so antibiotics should help for
him Okay now what's going on with the
goat um he had the poops a couple weeks
ago skinny yeah dirty butt and when I
picked him up today to bring him he was
um weak oh
still white bab okay let me get a feal
out of him on physical exam you find out
that the mucosal membranes especially in
the eyes and the mouth are pale that
means that most likely there are some
parasites there and that's why an animal
like this is anemic and the MOS is a
pale there's a little bit there okay let
me find
out more nothing nothing not pushing no
than COI is no closer to delivering her
puppies if the hormones and minerals
have no effect the next step is
surgical oh my
goodness coidis there's whole bunch of
them in
there this one to be how much
I don't know 10B really that's it
yeah okay so he gets a quarter pill
twice a day for 10 days then you can
stop for 10 days if you still has
diarrhea you do it
again
no you're fine okay see out wormed this
is for the others good okay
[Music]
BR nothing
huh
okay we'll do a
C-section
okay okay we need hands surgery is the
last
resort Bingo the puppies have to come
out we ready I am
too oh boy grab it grab them what we do
now is do a C-section go ahead there's
another one so when you open up you just
make sure that get every single one out
and as fast as possible and here's one
more or two more there and here's the
last
one that's it okay get busy without Mom
to lick the puppies Chris and Missy
mimic the
action
shoot the friction warms the puppies and
hopefully stimulates their
breathing will you check this yellow
one
oh my Lord I got
squeakers there you go how many do we
have out three and these were all in one
utherus horn that's why she couldn't get
it
[Music]
out
girl
girl girl
[Music]
boy we're just thankful for live puppy
as always five healthy squeaking
puppies yeah
okay all set I'm all
set thankful to be going home okay when
we get home we're going to let koogi
rest and recover and she had been
through a lot all night and all day so
was time get her home and
[Music]
comfortable it's the end of
October today is Halloween so the staff
has dressed up in our
costumes this is a velociraptor I'm
already the C I was going to say that
why didn't you I don't
know it's always a fun time for
us for
humans and Felons two hands Tommy T
didn't his at each other he quit ping
but that was
all although Tater would prefer Tommy
not get too
comfortable Tater is very
Territorial and does not want any other
cats running around in the clinic
all right guys ready out here hanging on
for a second you sit a quick snap of the
ghoulish good looks all right there you
go guys and it's right back to
[Music]
work sorry I didn't mean to scare you
Brutus is a walker and plot mix he's
about four or 5 years
old has big ear M that's what makes him
cute yeah he has a absess on his left
[Music]
cheek we've tried multiple things to
take the absess away penicillin
antibiotics it just kept coming
back hello hi this must be
burus this is Brutus hi bud and we tried
everything Brutus owners have been
trying to help them out as best as they
can but when I aspirate the lump
definitely it looks like there's an
infection what I'd like to do is clip
this and put a little puncture in it so
that it can drain a little bit he's
pretty calm so I I think I'll be able to
do it with just some local tment without
having to sedate him but we'll go to
that right now and we'll be right back
all right come on Sir come on buddy
though Brutus is a Fearless hunting
dog good
boy today he is quite the scaredy
cat come on
bud so we're going to put a little local
on that lump clip it open it
up I want to drain as much of the fluid
out of here as possible and treat it
from the inside out oh boy as long as we
keep the infection draining out and he's
getting the appropriate antibiotic
dosage and frequency I think this
infection should
resolve all your buddies are going to be
so
jealous he just looks so like defeated
poor guy come on
Mister you can still walk with it I
swear he wants the towel he's like no we
have
it he doesn't like slidy floors good
[Music]
boy I just suck this bandage on so he
doesn't bleed in the car just take it
off when you get home so that it can
drain again let me know in like a week
or so how he's doing you might need to
do antibiotics for a longer period of
time just as long as it's
improving
hi yeah I'm feeling really confident
that it's going to heal up
[Music]
finally look who's here look who's there
two special guests are excited to join
today's party Are You The Pick of the
pet Abigail and Silas get to share their
first Halloween weirdly because it was
cancelled last year so the two of them
are coming over to trick or treat with
and opa that doesn't look like does
it no take
off well you don't look like you either
you got little ears on tricker treat you
haven't seen me
enough it's always fun to see the kids
come in have some cake you got frosting
on there yeah that's a good part
[Music]
huh thank God you were home I know I
have a pow belly pig named scooter he's
approximately 5 years old and this
morning he was attacked by two
dogs I don't want him going into
shock he's got a pretty nasty gash on
his ear and he's got many puncture
wounds all over his face Scooter's my
sweetest Pig and I'm upset that he got
hurt like this poor
bud that's the P belly
pig he's got a Nice Slice behind his ear
here and he's got some puncture he's got
some by his eye how old's still he's
still shaking though hey go TR to bite
meat see there's just a little cut there
see that that's just draining the rest
is just running down and that's not wor
throwing up okay good news Scooter's
largest wound is
superficial and the other one I want to
see the other side
I got a door on this side okay good shut
this
yeah
gosh see this here that is actually the
worst that one is yeah
okay the dogs tore open a gash on
scooters right ear if I put a staple in
here that most likely will
hold she has a couple scrapes there's
one little cut and the main thing is
right by the ear but there is a bigger
hole if I put a staple in there would
you let me do it good luck with that one
I'll be right back okay don't get no
ideas that pole fix you up
[Music]
buddy just take it
easy
that was easier than I thought the
Staples probably can stay in several
weeks spray with disinfectant that's all
you have to do okay I think he'll be
fine just spray all of his little spray
yeah there's this one and the one on the
other side and then that
ear I think that's good enough all right
thanks oh not as bad as I thought it was
yeah I thought it was worse
too happens all the time all right thank
you yep I'm feeling great and it looks
great and I'm sure he'll do great all
pigs like their butts
scratched I'm sure Scooter's pretty
tired today after everything that
happened to him but he'll recover at
home just
[Music]
fine knock knock our neighbor Jake is
coming today doc hello Jake you see you
he has a daughter who loves kittens and
he was looking for a k
doc said that he had a nice cat that was
a feral cat but it was very sweet come
on let's have a look this way then you
can find him a home for kids that want a
cat like this that's just the perfect
thing you pick him up and he PS what's
his name well you called him Tommy the
Tom Cat because that's all it was he is
just the sweetest guy around oh yeah
he's cool he's very docile very nice
very friendly so I'm excited I know my
daughter's going to be very excited you
think kids will like it I think Athena
is going to lose her mind that's I think
she's going to go
crazy diant Tommy is going next door oh
oh I'm glad to see that Tommy's going to
have a good home and he'll be right next
door so I will be able to see him when I
want to good thank you good luck awesome
thank you so much that is a perfect
match
Perfect all
right all right you ready Tom
Cat this little Kitty's found a home all
right let's do it
dude this little kitty is
hurt o it looks kind of
irritated Cal is here with
Mo somehow he has injured his eye we
aren quite sure what happened he's a
very skittish Cat s guy I'm just
concerned about that eye I hope it's
nothing too bad where you might have to
have surgery or something on it just
something
simple looks like he tore his third
eyelid every cat and dogs as well have
the nicating membrane as it is
officially called but it's basically
just a thin extra layer of tissue that
can moisturize and clean the corny of
the eye very quickly without actually
having to Blink it can just kind of
flick across but that's what this little
flap is
okay I don't see any damage to the eye
itself there's just a lot of irritation
yeah well him and his brother like to
wrestle so yeah I wonder if he got like
a claw in his eye or something like that
and that's what tore that third eyelid
okay I'm going to um put a little bit of
um some numbing on there and then I can
just kind of
trim the the Flappy part off and then
we'll put him on some antibiotics for
his
eye okay and we'll be right back okay
bye buddy take good care of
them this little flap that's hanging
will probably heal faster if that kind
of loose part is just quickly
removed I have to do a minor eye
surgery just Miner just
Miner first I'm just going to apply a
little bit of local anesthetic to numb
the eyelid so Mo isn't feeling any of
what I'm going to do next perfect and
then quickly remove the loose
tissue
bam I'm going to have Cal treat with
some topical antimicrobial ointment but
I think it should heal up pretty quickly
now that the offending Flappy piece of
eyelid has been removed all right mister
okay
bye no wait forg
all right he did fantastic awesome you
might notice a small amount of like
bloody discharge for the rest of today
but with the ointment that will take
care of the infection and then the
irritation will all heal
up okay just in a few
days thank you very much you're very
welcome he did great he's my little
buddy when I get him all home we're
going to give him some good kitty treats
and just treat them
[Music]
right where are
they maybe there but see that's hard to
get there too Doc and Charles are trying
to find their next patient and that's
not where the horses are there's no
horses
here where the heck to keep the
horses Come Around The Way You Came the
first
time my horse covia is a secretary of
granddaughter and she's 28 years old
she's been my favorite horse I've had
her since she's been four years
old hi Sherry Hi here's the deal
chateau's been a little grumpy lately I
want you to look at her yeah but if
she's in pain I'm afraid just get a
halter on her and I'll have a feel and a
look all right the ecoin dentist
suggested she may even have a tooth
disease and is in a great deal of pain
and I'm afraid that I'll have to put her
down and I'm not ready to do that
yet come on sweet good girl Sher has
this older horse and it's losing weight
very good girl aren't you you're old
oh stand
still I would love to hear that there's
no disease I hope there's no tooth
pulling and that somehow she's just
going to be
okay holy cow look the front teeth are
terrible yeah the teeth are wore down to
the gums that is no points on there at
all these teeth here don't hurt you
can't you it because the teeth are wore
out see yeah
when the teeth are bad and they cannot
chew it so good they do not get enough
saliva sometimes they get a plug theopus
so these older horses really benefit
from good nutrition in them and they
last for a long time what we need to do
is a big diet
change most grains are pelleted but
extruded is like a cooked thing so
there's no need for them to chew and it
doesn't plug up that is arus they make
plenty of beads that are for more senior
horses that are having these type of
problems to allow them to be able to gum
their food or have it dissolve in their
mouth we putting weight on the horse and
that's what I want you to do first okay
Sherry this is good I am so happy I'm so
amazed I was expecting the worst I was
really not looking forward to this call
at all I was so afraid I'd have to put
her down no I'm totally elated
totally wait a minute yes does anybody
like sardines
here what I don't eat sardines does
anybody like sardines here I'll take
sardines yeah you yeah all right you
don't like
them oh little mayonnaise on the CER oh
yeah how many people give you sardines
not many but we'll use them yeah we'll
use them thank you give give me
I've been a client of Dr P's for 28
years we gotting old together you know
that and I love him he's a very good vet
love what Dr Paul does thank you we'll
see
[Music]
you a
baby out here at Chris's to take a look
at his young calf you're so cute the
calf is very bouncy and playful but
hasn't been bearing weight on one of its
front legs Chris wasn't able to be here
at the same time but he's concerned
about a pretty severe
injury
ow its elbow joint is very swollen and
painful I don't feel any bone on bone
scraping or fracture dislocation or
anything like
that I'm suspicious of a joint
infection so I'm going to poke it with a
needle I'm going to tap the joint to see
if it's swollen from infection or if
there's some other fluid in there or
what the situation is just to get me a
bit more
information trying to distract
him sometimes the best way to distract a
calf is to give them something to suck
on I'm sorry I don't have any snacks for
you I'll give them something else to
think about while I'm kind of doing
things that aren't as pleasant he know
that's not really food and since I don't
have anybody else here to restrain the
calf kind of have to be a little bit
creative
oh P nasty confirms Dr Lisa's
suspicion joint infections can happen in
young calves from septicemia which they
can get from either pneumonia or an
umbilical
infection joint infections can be
difficult to resolve completely and this
one looks pretty severe I know stop
moving but I'm hoping that systemic
antibiotics are going to be enough to
clear it
up I feel
weird hi Chris this is Dr Jones calling
from pette a course of antibiotics and
hopefully this calf can grow up happy
and healthy if you have any question
questions uh just give me a call and we
can talk more about it otherwise have a
great afternoon
bye to
mobile go right
[Music]
ahead want to exray on her um probably
probably will be let's get your
back this morning I let the dogs out the
back door we'll have after for you just
okay as I was walking out I heard a
thud she I heard my dog yelping and I
ran out the door and she got hit by a
car I know it probably hurts Sly I'm
sorry I'm
trying I yelled for her and as I was
running down the driveway she come
around the corner she was limping pretty
good wouldn't put no weight on her back
left
foot good morning good morning how are
you could be better right so what's
going on with Cam what happened I heard
a thud and her yeling okay she can't
stra coming to
me can she stand at all it's all right
baby girl hang
on good girl okay lay down that's fine
too we're going to do a physical exam
and look at the body and look to see if
she's been injured somewhere banged up
yeah looking for fractures mostly I
moved it earlier and she helping
depending on where the force and the
pressure was applied to the body of the
dog when the car hit
it I'm not finding anything that feels
broken on that
set now is there some looseness in her
pelvis which might be puppiness and
might be something else we're going to
take some x-rays there's some
instability in her hips and I want to
see what that looks like by x-ray all
right I'll take her there is something
that's different than normal here and we
were going to use the X-ray to help us
diagnose what that different than normal
really is all right hang on here
sweetie really concerned about anything
being broken My Hope Is that she'll just
heal and nothing worse let trying to
leave my light up on her back too she
goes everywhere with me she does
everything with me she's the world it's
you're all right you're all right you're
all
right yes you did not like that did
you so with camel's x-rays today the
good news is there's no fractured bones
and what I see is there's a dislocation
between our sacrum and our
hips called a sacroiliac luxation the
bones that connect the spine and the
pelvis are
separated all right this is not an
uncommon finding with a hit by car okay
yeah this causes the back end to be sort
of wobbly and more wobbly than normal in
a
puppy so what she's done is she's
dislocated her pelvis when you put your
H BS you can feel unsteady move so it's
going to take a little bit for that to
solidify
again she could go to a referral place
for surgery if the owners are interested
in having some plates put in to help
stabilize this quicker if you wanted a
perfect pelvic fix she needs surgery to
have that done the other way to help her
heal was letting nature take its course
and help bind those bones back together
ideally she goes outside leash walks
only for about 3 or 4 weeks okay and not
a whole lot of run and loose being crazy
she just needs it to be
quiet so I will get some pain meds for
her okay the good news is she's a puppy
the bone structure there is already in a
growth phase so it actually helps her
heal faster from this injury so she gets
these and they're flavored and some of
them will take them for a treat and
she's like oh not so much today there we
go down here all right we'll get you
headed for home all right I feel
relieved a little concerned about trying
to keep her on a leash cuz she doesn't
like leash she's not going to be happy
but she'll be all right
[Music]
we're going this
side Oscar is a 4-year-old boxer he's a
mama's
boy come on his personality is wherever
I'm at he's at and that's kind of what
clued me into that something was
wrong this morning he just wasn't
himself he just wasn't like hey Mom
where are we going he was like Hey I'm
not going anywhere hi good morning how
are you I am better than the dog right
right yeah looks scared yeah he's
normally not a scared dog in the four
years that we've had him he's never had
an illness so yeah it's very
concerning come on huh what's the
problem can you say hi no huh what's the
problem this is what happens when dogs
when they don't feel good
they act differently good pet owners
will notice that and this is why car is
bringing them in let's start with taking
a temperature it's okay sweet it's okay
he is just not himself he's usually just
a happy dog oh he's got a temperature no
we talking
1031 now we even know why he didn't feel
good right right it's 103 that means it
just has a little temperature has he
been outside too long or so he's a farm
dog so he's outside with me it's been
been raining and everything did he get
wet a couple times probably probably
this crazy weather I think that's what
it is it sounds like he has a cold and
you see that quite a bit in animals
because it gets hot it gets cold we put
a cat on take a coat off those animals
cannot do it okay I'm going to give him
a shot and we put him on pills hopefully
he'll just snap right out of it thanks
doctor Oscar's going to be fine some
antibiotics will take care of it and
hopefully that know the weather will
straighten out and he'll just run with
her all over the farm it's okay yes
don't be so scared you're the boxer huh
yes okay he's nice go for ride we're
going to keep an eye on him and hope he
bounces right back to his perky sth
he's going to have a lot of couch time
this weekend he's totally okay with that
and I'm not going to complain
[Music]
either
sh this fall Sherry feared the worst
when her horse chatau via was losing
weight
girl Dr pul said let's try her feed and
Chateau has done there well on
that before her ribs were quite
pronounced but now it's hard to even
seal them so
wonderful I love the trail ride so I'm
hoping to do more of that with chatau
this
summer what are you doing
Kitty my daughter wanted a cat doc said
hey we have a great solution for that
and we have this nice Tom Cat would you
like to take him home with
[Music]
you he's a really nice friendly cat if I
could keep him out of the dog food you
know you having fun you find a piece of
fuzz my daughter insisted that we switch
his name so it's not Tom Cat socks s Sox
to be specific she would ensure that you
get it correct what's up socks what you
doing bubba he's probably one of the
coolest cats I've ever dealt with he
just loves to cuddle and you know be pet
and be around people he's very
affectionate he wants to be held and
played with and he's very
[Music]
happy